hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well as we've
been discussing this evening Northern
Ireland's largest unionist party is
likely to hold the key to Rishi Cena
getting any deal over the protocol
across the line now that is because many
in his own party will look to the dup
when deciding whether to approve any
proposal now this was the Prime Minister
earlier he was responding to the dep
leader Sir Jeffrey Donaldson at Primus
questions I've heard loud and clear when
he says he wants and needs these issues
resolved so that he has a basis to work
with others to restore power sharing and
I know that that is genuine he raised
the question of practical issues and it
is vital that these are addressed but he
also raises Mr Speaker a vital question
about the Constitutional and legal
framework in which these Arrangements
exist and I can assure him that I agree
addressing the Democratic deficit is an
essential part of the negotiations that
remain ongoing with the European Union
and just as he has been consistent so
have I and I can assure him that this is
at the very heart of the issues that
must be addressed
well that was the Prime Minister a
little uh earlier I'm delighted to say
that we do have the dep's health
spokesperson Jim Shannon on the program
today to give us a bit of light uh into
what the dep are thinking when it comes
to brexit before we get there though I
would like to just reflect a bit on the
news that we've had this morning about
the shooting in Omar what do you know if
anything about what's happened oh well
uh probably things are very sketchy to
be honest
um the reports are coming through that
are a police officer has been shot
um I I think I I Zen Uma I I know all
were very well I was born there I
probably don't know very much about it
as a retail but there was my area where
we came from
um almost always been a one of those
historic places for me a a country time
but also the memories of the 29 people
were murdered in that Ira bomb a way
back some years ago but um I think we
just first would say my my absolute
thoughts prayers of everyone all decent
people are with uh with that family uh
and hoping things are okay
um but it does perhaps remind us
unfortunately uh that there are evil
people out there who have evil
intentions uh and they don't care who
the targets are and they they involve
their chosen someone who
um was vulnerable at that time uh and
and we just have to pray for for his uh
betterment and and for his healing and
and also for the family yeah really um
reports as you say uh coming out of uh
County Tyrone with the shooting of that
police officer she said the details
still coming through now
um
do you think it's a reminder of the
fragility of Northern Ireland and the
peace there
I think so if we need to prepare over
the years we've seen a dramatic change
in in life in the province um many
people served in the ultra defense
regiment and the British Army and the
police give their contribution give
their lead every myself my own family
we've lost uh loved ones uh dear friends
as well we always remember them never
forget them
um I I think those are they're clear
issues but it tells us what was the past
is like now has terrorism ridges
certainly at hands but it doesn't take a
whole lot of people to to keep it going
and it's quite clear to all of us that
uh from the from the information we give
from the police uh that there's still
this Republicans out there who are
intent upon creating havoc on murder as
they will I mean we had a bomb uh in in
last weekend as well so so there's a
reminder nearly every week of something
I mean our place um are very good their
intelligence Services is excellent they
probably they have infiltrated I suspect
it doesn't to some extent but evil
people can do evil things and tonight
we've been reminded of just art and talk
to us a bit about Omar you were born
there you say it has a history doesn't
it yeah well yeah a real uh
um I suppose I always take great
pleasure and tell people to come
remember and Vicki forward the MP by the
way concerned about me she was born in
Rome as well so we're to uh I'm not sure
that because all my organians or
something I'm not sure what they they're
terminology would be but but uh yeah
we're very proud of our history I I
think we we we often and Uma even back
in my
um 10 years ago uh what was that was a
city where there was division but of
course and those early days back in then
I think my mother always tells me
Mother's 91 still living by the way
um as he always tells me that that uh
the relationship between the two
communities and her days when she was
small and that wasn't yesterday uh was
always good they they had their
differences but they lived together uh
the troubles brought change and brought
difference and brought the dissension uh
and and conflict
um but Uma was always a sharing light I
always thought on the way uh and our
community that could work together and
do well
I want to talk to you a little bit about
uh bricks that we heard there of course
where she's like responding to Jeffrey
Johnson obviously at dep
th close are we do you think to a deal
that could be acceptable to the DP
um I wish it was that's what I would say
to you yeah reality
um
I I don't see that at this moment
there's our parties are very clear
mandate we fought on Election on it with
a mandate to deliver to the people and
we're honest people and I believe in
honestly in politics as our party does I
I think we have to ensure that what we
have as a man did is delivered with a
seven point plan uh Jeffrey Johnson has
given incredible leadership and he's
very clear and we had a parliamentary
meeting this week and he was as clear as
can be no doubt seven point plan that's
what I need to address how far are we
getting there on that seven point plan
um 3.5 yeah really halfway you think
then positive people yeah but but it's
not it's not about are we are we three
quarters of the way there are we almost
there I'm gonna have the whole lot we
it's not a point there's clear issues
when you heard I heard that what Jeffrey
said I've sent this item uh but I heard
uh his comment and he referred to the
the Constitutional position there's big
issues I mean
I suspected the things that they're able
to address or the the small mechanical
issues the mechanism of how how
something would work you know it was a
small fry ones big issues are
constitutional position
other big massive issue is the European
court of justice Authority must always
lie with West there what's the name of
the Westminster not with Brussels final
decision and anything that we don't
agree with has to come back to the
Sovereign part and The Sovereign power
is Westminster you see any listings he
said obviously as you're saying there
that it would be unacceptable for EU
laws to be imposed on Northern line and
so that the jurisdiction of the European
courts of Justice a red line he also
said that the treaty needs to be
Rewritten now frankly the EU isn't going
to agree to that is it so it feels to me
like
there isn't going to be a deal that the
dep will agree to well Sophie I'm the
eternal optimist and life I I always uh
and all my life always uh trying to be
the half-class full person around the
half class empty uh and this one I I I
find it very difficult to see it as half
transfer because I don't see an
agreement imminent
um now it's imminent I mean the EU said
it won't agree to those things so it's
not it's not going to happen right uh
well well if the EU don't uh um adjust
their their demands in a way that gives
us as part of the United Kingdom the
same rights uh I always I said at the
day and and the comments and I always
remember Margaret Thatcher's comments
where she said you know uh Ulster is as
British eventually well no it's not not
anymore under the present agreement so I
want to see us having the same rights in
Northern Ireland as they have in in
London and Cardiff in Plymouth and
Newcastle and indeed and and Edinburgh
and Glasgow as well I guess the
difficulty right is if if the UK isn't
part of the European Union anymore there
needs to be a border right where is that
order going to be
well I I mean we were able in the past
to have a the Border online where we're
using the United Kingdom more part uh we
in Northern Iowa were part of the United
Kingdom I think that's where where if
it's going to be a border that's where
it needs to be not down down there on
the island of Ireland yes I mean that is
going to be for many people just
something that they would never count on
us because of the history right yeah but
I think we've got to remember shortly
that the the border that was was a very
poorest Border in a way uh they they
mean very very few custom checks on it
but it doesn't matter at the time did it
because we were part of the single
Market yeah but but uh I'm I'm old
enough uh uh to uh as a child but my mum
and daughter and my dad said no my
mother's still living and she's old
enough to remember the Border we my dad
was from today called my mother was from
Claudio were uh I say strabane so they
the the Border was I know there's a
difference of the of the uh Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland but
let's be honest it was never that hard
there's a way of doing things I think uh
we we um look there's always a solution
the solution in this life with Europe
and it lies clearly the balls of their
toes we're going to play football and
they've got a they've got a pair right I
want to talk to you a little bit about
number 10 number she seen it and because
it does it does make me wonder whether
there's been a bit of political naivety
here from number 10 do you think they
should have involved the dup a bit
earlier I guess in some of these
discussions
um
well yes
yeah yeah they should have uh to
suddenly uh descend uh um from on high
uh in Belfast and Freddie Freddie last
week uh with the conceived plan that
they thought that they could then
deliver without us knowing in any
discussions any talks with what was
going on
um I I look I would wish Ritchie soon as
well I I hope and pray that he can
deliver an agreement but the reality is
I mean so far we don't
include the main participants in in the
process and it's not a visit on a Friday
with that with a chopping ring with five
parties they tell them oh by the way
guys here's what I've got uh what do you
think uh no well I'll tell you what
we're quite clear but we think seven
point plan uh address the issue of the
European court of justice and ensure
that word is British as British in
Northern Ireland which I don't just feel
my concessions don't feel that a
unionists don't Freed at this moment I
guess some people on the opposite side
of the argument might be thinking look
the current situation there are issues
with the current situation right now
someone is even functioning there isn't
even a functioning government in
Northern Ireland isn't it time for the
dup to compromise a bit as well are you
making perfect the enemy of good
um we're starting off with good so I'm
not making any perfect anime because we
we believe that uh We've among it to
deliver a constitution base do you have
a mandate to deliver you don't have a
majority on the assembly in favor of the
protocol well we have and within the
unions every unionist that there is at
the Northern Ireland assembly are
opposed to the protocol so from a union
Tony player uh two examples Tony Blair
uh albertia Hearn uh both of them have
said there can be no deal without a
participation and full involvement of
universe up until now we haven't had
that full involvement so I think we
we're at a stage where where
um prominent
politicians here and and the United
Kingdom but also in Ireland are
indicating that we have to be part of
that process you can deliver whatever
you want if Government voices to but if
we aren't bought into that process the
universe people aren't part of that
process there's a stem for failure and
now I want to ask you the question that
David Bevins suggested to me uh when I
said that you were coming on he said I
should ask you what do you regret the
most supporting brexit which meant that
there would have to be a border
somewhere or not voting for The Theresa
major when you have the chance
and I heard you and I heard him I was
thinking about it and and hear from the
city and and I'll say we're all in and
we're all like sort of Okay cookie you
can't make your mind on my own I'm out
I'm singing it all about that's not how
it works uh we're all uh part of the
United Kingdom we're Britain North now
within brexit or we're not all together
so I my answer to that one is uh uh we
we wish to be I I love my business I I
whenever I first came to to Parliament
Islands one of the first guys it's
always referred people refer to that
again I referred to the United Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland
and that Mantra members were a reminder
to money on the chamber it's very very
much helpfulness for me it's not for
making students so uh what do we regret
the most but neither were good and for
not good then they're not we're not
going to buy on debt so um we're not in
but we want to be alongside what they
what Boris Johnson and and his consents
have in London and and what they have in
Newcastle and what album Cardiff what
happened Glasgow in Edinburgh it's not
too much to ask for the Union's
population this can never succeed if
there's no buy-in from unionism okay
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much